Hi everyone and welcome. I was looking on AliExpress recently and I came across this.
This is a little audio amplifier kit and it's based on the LM386 audio amplifier and I thought
this would be really good fun to try out with this. This is a little personal FM radio kit that I
recently did a review on so if you're interested please pop across my channel. This only cost three
dollars but obviously it's designed to just take a headphone or a connection there rather than a
speaker. I thought this would be really good fun to see how it sounded through this little amplifier.
So let's open this up and see what we've got. You get a little circuit diagram as you can see.
there but to be honest the PC board itself actually comes with all the components identified on so
hopefully construction shouldn't be too much of a problem. The LM386 itself this is the LM386 N1
version and the N1 is good for around about 325 milliwatts so that's plenty to be honest just to
drive a small speaker. Luckily it comes in an 8 pin DIL package that's really neat because a lot of the
kits also provide sort of SMD sort of versions or surface mount versions and they're a real pain to
solder. They even give you a little 8 pin sort of socket there for it which is a neat touch.
Volume control that also is full size rather than a skeleton type and it will give you a little knob
there just to sort of make life just a little bit easier. So even though this is budget they've
actually put a little bit of thought into it. So what I'm going to do now I'm going to assemble it,
I'll solder it all up and then we're going to see how she's sound so let's get on with the build.
Okay so our little amplifier board now is fully populated. I'm also connected up a loud speaker,
simply just connecting to the audio output pins there as you can see. I also made up a small power
supply in the shape of a PP3 clip connected to a small female jack. Just remember to make the center
pin there the positive. I'm just going to connect this up now to our little amplifier board. LED light
comes on which is good. What I'm going to do is I'm going to pop up on the screen for you the schematic
diagram for this little amplifier. The reason for doing this is this little LM386 chip has actually
got a neat little party trick. It's as much as you can actually adjust the gain. If you look at pins 1
and 8 then if there's nothing connected to them then the internal resistance sets the gain at 20.
However if you connect a 10 microparad capacitor between pins 1 and 8 then the gain is increased to
200 and in fact that's what our little board has got. If you want something in between simply put a
1.2k resistor in series with that capacitor and the gain reduces to around about 50. Okay back to our
little amplifier then. What I want to do is just connect up this little personal FM radio kit that I spoke
about earlier in the video and just see as you perform. So I'm just going to simply just connect to
the audio out and then connect to the audio in on the board. I'm going to put the speaker on the cloth
because it can vibrate on this board a little bit. I'm going to turn it up.
the volume works okay.
That's actually not bad. What I'm going to do is just connect up a little mp3 player and just see
how that performs. What I've got is this little TDV26. This is a useful little device to be honest.
It's an FM radio come mp3 player. It's also got bluetooth. It's a brick on the back if you wish it.
But it's only cost a few dollars and I've actually done a review on this if you want to pop a
graph on channel and have a look at that. I'm simply just going to connect to the audio out on that.
So I'm just going to pop a USB stick in there. Connect up to the audio out. Let's switch it on.
That's actually not bad at all. I'm just going to switch that off.
Okay so there you have it. It's a little LM386 audio amplifier kit. To be honest for the price it's an
absolute bargain. You can keep yourself a few of these because perhaps you want to do some audio
work or maybe repair radios and you just want a trusted amplifier just so you can look at the
front end of your radios. There's all sorts of things you can do with this. So anyway appreciate
you watching. Hopefully you found it useful. If you did give me that thumbs up. As always appreciate you
watching and I'll catch up with you soon.